okay
I'm so glad some I read this what do you
make of the research emerging this week
that suggests underground microbes on
Mars suck so much hydrogen out of the
air and caused dramatic climate change
on the planet I read this and what it
said was that they think around the time
that life formed in our oceans about 3.7
million years ago billion years
obviously yes uh where I know what day
that would be on the cosmic calendar
would that be about September on the
cosmic I remember my Cosmic calendar I
love the cosmic I love the cars we all
love the cosmic calendar so that's
around September of the cosmic calendar
okay so and the the same thing could
have happened on Mars we we there was
microbes but they ate the hydrogen and
then emitted methane gross
and that caused they said before that
Mars could have been up balmy 68 degrees
but that caused the pla the planet The
Runaway conduct of a species uh can have
dramatic consequences to all other life
in that ecosystem don't we know it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so without naming Nick
um about I'm remembering the Dutch elm
disease that took out all the Dutch Elms
in the Northeast and so now they're no
Dutch Helms and so I don't know what the
disease is now attacking but it doesn't
have to was there life on Mars 3.7
billion years there's we don't have
reason to doubt it because the
ingredients of life
hydrogen oxygen carbon nitrogen are
everywhere in the universe and you're
throwing a little bit of Water and Light
got going almost as quickly as it
possibly could have on Earth and if Mars
had those conditions earlier than Earth
did it may be that Mars that Mars was
the birth of life in the inner solar
system and asteroid impacts we know can
send rocks into space and they land on
Earth it's called pan spermia it may be
that everyone on Earth is a descendant
of martians so sometimes we should let
the asteroids hit oh my God
sometimes it's a good thing
I love the way you gloss over that point
where and life got going so that's a
hard it's a frontier I know I'm just
saying that that's kind of a big divide
there there was no life there was just
the elements and then life got going the
elements and then there's organic
chemistry and then there was life but
that was pretty short in the timeline of
the earth well I heard some credit for
figuring out how to make that work all
right all right
Michael as a Pennsylvanian do you think
it's fair that John fetterman has he's
running for Senate there has been
subject to so much scrutiny after his
stroke
he hasn't been subject to enough
scrutiny
a free ride my view he needs to be
covered with both empathy and
objectivity I think he's been covered
entirely with empathy and not enough
objectivity an NBC reporter who's doing
a toss with Lester Holt before setting
up an interview that she did with
fetterman explained that before the
interview began and before he was
afforded the opportunity to use closed
captioning he was having difficulty
understanding her question in making
small talk huge blowback against her for
having the audacity to admit that that's
ridiculous and by the way I think it
speaks to some of the tribalism that you
addressed in tonight's program because
it's not only on on the right and their
willingness to just ignore the
deficiencies of of Herschel Walker it's
going on in this as well we don't know
if he's okay
cognitively he says it's only a
processing issue and as a Pennsylvanian
I'd like to know but he'll only do one
debate and not until a lot of people
have voted and that's not enough okay
thank you very much thank you great
crowd tonight I appreciate it